hey youtubers is charlie and monday
during my game of thrones breakdown i
asked you to submit all your questions
about season four so now it's time for
some answers in case you missed it i
also announced the special video
countdown series that i'm going to be
doing starting in about two weeks that
will run for the month of march as we
get closer to season four once we get to
Episode one that'll also be the
beginning of my weekly game of thrones
giveaway it'll be just like my Walking
Dead weekly giveaway that I'm doing
right now if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to
participate in that it's gonna be super
fun happy time with dragons but now
let's get to your questions so number
one comes from reyne of castamere haha I
suit you did there how are they going to
explain Jamie returning to early to
King's Landing and is Bronn going to
accompany Jamie to Riverrun in order to
completely fulfill ill and pains role so
they're actually not going to do
anything special Jamie's story is just
gonna push into book for in the trailer
we did see that twincest reunion shot as
well as you know white cloaks and
oathkeeper so that's basically all
booked for stuff to answer your brawn
question yes we saw him train Jamie to
fight with his left hand it's likely
that he's basically just going to take
over all that part that Ilyn Payne would
have normally had just because the actor
who plays him is really sick with cancer
and brawn has a much bigger part on the
show right now so it just makes more
sense to use them the difference you'll
notice and that is mostly just the fact
that there will be exponentially greater
wisecracking as Ilyn Payne does not have
the tongue to match question number two
all the world's a stage asks how deep
into dance with dragons and feast for
crows territory is season for pushing
with the characters like Brianne Danny
bran and Theon and what kind of pressure
does it put on george RR martin to get
the winds of winter out there i don't
think it's going to cover all those
books it's just like season 3 did not
cover all of clash of kings but i'd say
you know based on the footage we've seen
they'll get at least half way through
books four and five the key to
determining how far ahead in the story
they're going to go is looking at Sansa
scenes because if you look with those
scenes with Sansa in the area in the
trailer i think they happen
chronologically the latest in the story
question number 37 thelma tasks do you
think we'll see the Aria Faceless Ones
narrative explored this season the coin
yes but there's been no indication that
they've filmed on sets that they haven't
already built yet so unless somewhere
that they've already filmed you know
like in northern island where the river
lions are is going to double for that
next place she goes they're not going to
do it so far the only new location sets
we know about this season are the marine
sets
most likely that the furthest look out
with her story is her trying to use the
coin there's been no evidence as they
film scenes that occur chronologically
after that in the books if they do
continue to stay true to the books I
think we'll see that next place she goes
in season five though question number
four link Carlton asks how many more
seasons realistically do you think Game
of Thrones can go for so they plotted
seven seasons but HBO could always you
know come at the end of that time and
say hey we want a season eight and just
back a dump truck of money up to their
doorstep question number five SVC asks
who is your favorite character so my
favorite character always changes from
season to season last season it was a
tie between Jamie and Brienne but this
season I think it's gonna be Jamie he
only gets more interesting so you should
definitely keep your eyes on him it's
gonna be a lot of fun question number
six Mia pickle tests in what episode do
you think the purple wedding will be in
so based on the breakdown I did you know
we saw slides for episode 6 in episode 5
so I'm gonna say episode 4 tentatively
it could be sooner but it's definitely
not the first episode so it's somewhere
between two three and four question
number 7 living like Lannisters ha nice
name do any book readers have an idea of
what that scene with drogon it is so if
you have dance with dragons it's that
scene that they talked about during
chapter 11 so in the trailer there's a
scene of an old man bringing Danny a
sack of bones that's the scene that
precedes you know with that old man
comes to do george RR martin did not
write that scene in so the show added it
either for dramatic effect or just to
give us the opportunity to see drogue on
roast someone remember last season he
did roast someone but this season he's
big enough to literally eat someone
alive question number 8 Jessica chatty
asks do you think we'll see Lady
Stoneheart in season 4 so I actually
have to talk a little bit about the
actress I won't say her name the actors
who would be playing her was on suits
for all of last year and it started at
least four movies since she left Game of
Thrones so there has been no evidence
that she was in Northern Ireland filming
scenes for that based on my earlier
comment that they'd only get part way
through books four and five it's totally
possible that she could be in season
five though so that's not a definitive
no she always could come back on and do
that cameo obviously the role isn't you
know a huge part it just depends on
where the show goes with the story
question number 9 Scarlett Moriarty asks
what scenes are you most excited
for I'm actually excited for a bunch of
stuff so let's count it off big dragons
Jaime in King's Landing and Arya and the
Hound in the Riverlands of all the
characters that go through changes the
biggest are the Dragons they literally
become a huge problem Jamie gets so much
more interesting and Arya gets super
dark I love The Odd Couple that she in
the Hound make really their scenes are
the most fun to watch question number 10
Yoda super Fanny asks do you post any
character reviews so like i said i'll be
doing that month-long countdown series
so here's some of the details about
what's gonna happen since there will be
so many Game of Thrones videos happening
in that time i'll definitely be doing
character videos history videos and all
kinds of stuff just based on what you
guys want to see since that's all going
to get started in about two weeks once
we get closer i'll announce what the
schedule is going to be you know what
kind of videos are going to happen on
what days so if you have anything that
you really want to see anybody just
write it below in the comments and i'll
add it to my list and one last bonus
question the maggies asks how close to
the book do you think that the wedding
scene will be so they went all out
Charles dance said that it is actually
like a short film based on that I think
that everything is in there from the
books everyone though the big question
is so funny is dwarfed jousting everyone
wants to know if there's going to be
dwarves and will they just I'll say yes
dwarves Joss ting is still a mystery I
don't expect to see jousting thank you
so much guys for submitting your
questions this is a lot of fun as always
until we get to that countdown series in
a couple weeks i'll probably do one Game
of Thrones video a week this friday i
will be doing a special Hannibal season
2 video will you please be my dinner
date we will be eating all the people
that you don't like I think once I move
into my new apartment I might try and
cook some of the Hannibal recipes sans
people meets though so right now click
here for all my season 4 breakdown
videos and click here for my latest
Walking Dead video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you